okay so our last speaker before lunch is
going to be love July you can talk about
grabsy compositions and their mini-games
thanks for the organizer for the
workshop want to talk about - without
that come up from our study after uni
games problem the first one is don't
work with my students with my students
method and the second without is also
don't work with Lima and Xianyang okay
so our original motivations for studying
the unique games problem is to consider
unique games on graphs with many small
eigenvalues it is because we know that
for graphs with few small icon values we
know how to solve unique games
effectively using the eigenspace
elimination technique of cola we you
know sometimes motivations and without
non-match we couldn't solve the problem
in such generality but we asked what are
some graphs that we know that have many
small capacity and eigenvalues and in
fact I think the only well-known graph
class with such property is graphed with
without kr minor three is kr manaphy
graphs and bounded genius graph so and
then we ask the questions can be solved
unity games if effectively on on such
graphs okay so that was our first
question so before I talk about what
unique games may be we just focus on the
simplest interesting case the maximum
cut problem so the maximum cut problem
we all know is we have a undirected
graph and then we just want to find a
partition of the vertex set into two
part and maximizing the number of edges
between the partition or equivalently
you can think about I want to find
partitions to minimize the number of
edges on the same side or if I remove
such edges then the graph becomes by
part I and I
I have a maxcut okay so I think about
the second person to mean and cut
problem okay I'm given a kr minor free
graft and I want to solve the minute a
problem what do we know about mean and
tab it's a classical without in 75 by
headlock that if you are given a
paragraphs then we can solve max cut and
so mean and cut exactly in general
graphs there's this without STP
approximation algorithms by choker Macau
Macau chef there's a lock and
approximate square lock and
approximation I don't know as far as I
know there's no no approximation
algorithms for K are minor free graphs
that do better than the general square
would lock an approximation so then we
asked this question and then with that
we show that for K are minor free graphs
we have an order approximation and then
for graph with genius at most G we have
a lock G approximation for for for mean
and cap so I want to show you the proof
of this place without
I think so I mean let's craft with genus
G every graph like when it is high
enough it is it is happy hard you can
use multi cut and multi cut has the
better approximation for K are minor
free craft but then you have to do this
reduction from your original graph to
some labor extended graph then you you
lost the kr minor freeness so this is
actually the technical issue that we
have to we have to handle that we cannot
work on the labor extended graph so let
me start we just write an LP relaxation
instead of STP relaxation we just write
an LP we want to find a minimum number
of edges to remove so that the remaining
graph is bipartite this is the mean and
cut problem and we just write this LP we
want to minimize the total cost of the
edges that we delete and then we want to
make the graph bipartite we want to
destroyed all the odd cycles so for each
cycle we want to remove at least one
edges for all our cycle C and then we
want this to be non-negative so this is
the LP relaxation that we use I think it
is known to be exact for for planar
graphs but I don't think we have an
efficient rounding algorithms for for
planar graphs I don't know maybe there
is so these are P is except for
paragraphs but if someone gives you a
solution do you know I don't know how to
how to run it
Oh max cut it's not integral
it is good because combinations
so maybe I can say something about this
these LP has exponentially many cons
faint but we can solve it effectively
using the ellipsoid algorithms using a
shortest path algorithm as our code
you think maybe many of you know but I
want to bring up this point like how do
you solve it if you have an edge UV what
we can do is we make two notes for each
for each node let's say u plus u minus V
Plus and V minus and then we draw such
an edge and then there's an O cycle you
know original graph if and only if
there's a path from V plus 2 V minors
and and if we want to check whether this
LP is satisfiable we just need to check
whether the shortest path from V Plus to
V minus is at least 1 for all V so if it
satisfied any satisfied this LP and I
want to bring up this point because this
is how people usually soft unique games
by constructing this label extended
graph so for each node depending on the
alphabet size you create multiple copies
of the same node but I just want to add
a remark that we cannot do this for for
our problem because even if you are
given a planar graph and you construct
this labor extender graph it could have
an opportunity large minor ok so we will
check our self to work on original graph
so what do we what do we do we use this
standard and powerful tool in in solving
problems in command free graphs low
diameter graphic above system it is used
in actually
many algorithms to design constant
factor approximation algorithms from
there many problems for this one is
closest to our work they use it to solve
the small cell expansion problem which
is known to be closely related to unique
games seven authors and I think six of
them are in this workshop and we use the
following version of the low diameter
graph decomposition it is not the
original form it is just a very simple
from the original paper is a very nice
paper and they prove much more not just
low diameter graph decomposition but
also patter decomposition and with
stronger properties
what is low diameter graph decomposition
we were given a weighted graph so each
Edge has a length W D and then given any
parameter Delta we can find the existed
distributions are partition such that
each edge is cut with probability if it
is km and every graph it is cut with
probability at most Big O of our x w e /
t
noda and after cutting the graph we have
this property for sure the diameter of
each cluster is is at most Delta the
diameter means it is a little subtle
there are different definition of the
diameter but it means for every pair of
no in in one part the distance in the
original graph is at most out our
it's a stronger person that even on the
induced graph the diameter is at most
Delta we would actually come back to to
that point
measure by W by pedaling function okay
so we're going to use this so how are we
going to use it what we want to solve
our problem we want to cut the graph
into by product component what do we
know we don't know how to cut into by
pattern components we only know how to
cut into lo diameter clusters so what do
we hope we hope that lo diameter
component which implies the graph is
bipartite so why it should be true most
natural approaches you set the length of
each edge to be the rational solution
you solve the LP you look at the XE and
then assign it to be the length of of
the edge and then what do we write in
the LP we set up for each odd cycle it
is long the total length is at least one
so suppose we can say that in such a
long cycle that exist a pair of note
that the shortest path distance is
greater than 1/4 and and we are good
then we can run the low diameter graph
decomposition with Delta equal to 1/4
and cut the graph and then some pair of
note in the our cycle would be separated
so that our cycle would would be killed
ok so if we can do that then that would
be good and then the expected cost would
be big off our LP it is because what
used to expect at us the expected costs
is some of the cost of each edge the
probability that it is cut but the
probability that it is cut in the low
diameter graph decomposition is just
Peggle of ow x w yi divided by delta we
choose delta to be constant and some of
c w yi is exactly the LP now we send it
to be XE it is exactly the LP value
so that is our pan but but the hope is
not always true for example you consider
this car I have an indigo solution I
choose these three edges to be cut but
shortest path distance between every
pair of node is zero you always have
some Co edges to go around it is a low
diameter cluster in the graph distance
sense but it is not bipartite you may
think that it is a silly example because
we already have the integral solution we
just need to pick other edges with one
and then we are done and and what we
observe is this with large rational
value is the only abstraction to to our
hope so we we prove this lemma suppose
all edges the fractional value is at
most 1/2 then for every for every other
cycle there exist a pair of node with
distance greater than one 1/4 so this is
the fix and and if this lemma is true
then we are done we can first pick all
the edges with rational values greater
than 1/2 we pay at most two times the lp
cost and then after that we run the
decomposition with Delta equal to 1/4
and this analysis would go through and
then we cut order we willing our cycles
okay so now to finish the proof I just
need to show you the lemma and I would
do proof picture
it is a simple
so I keep if I'm given an a cycle I want
to find a pair of notes with large
distance if I find such a pair then I'm
done
I know that lo diameter graph
decomposition would separate them so I
start from a note let's say I look at
this a cycle I look at let's say the mid
pond and then I compute a shortest path
distance from u to V if it is greater
than 1/4 I'm happy this can be separated
so if it's not true it is at most one
quarter I practiced a graph I purchased
a cycle into two part and then at least
one of them is odd so let's say the left
part is odd and then I would focus on
this part and then I let's say I look at
the midpoint again ask what is the
distance if it is greater than 1/4 and
done if it is not and then and then I
keep doing that and then I ask this
midpoint and then if it is every time
I'm doing this this becomes shorter and
shorter if I keep cannot find such a
large distance pair then it becomes
shorter and shorter and eventually it
would becomes one edge but this is an a
cycle the sum of the lengths is at least
one and then these two part is at most
one quarter so this edge would have
value at this 1/2 so that's tester proof
so that's that's our first result and
this is true for kr minus V graphs for
bounded genius graph G you just replace
everything of our by lucky because we
have stronger decomposition without 404
no tabata decomposition result for
poundage in this graph okay cycle cons
things that a cycle would be of total
length at least one and then these two
part the total length is at most one
quarter
as for the shortest cycle okay so now
maybe I can tell you what is the unique
games conjecture do we has already told
you about it I just consider a special
case this special case tooling with
alphabet size out so we are just given a
set of linear equations X I plus XJ is
equal to cij mod luau for some for some
R and we are given a bunch of such
linear equations and then the unique
games conjecture can be equivalently
stated as the following that for every
epsilon that exists a large enough hour
such that for this tool in our problem
it is empty hard to distinguish between
the two cases the first cases that
exists an assignment that satisfies 1
minus epsilon freshmen off constrained
the no case is no assignment satisfy
more than epsilon fashion of constraint
general you becames problem can be
reduced to the tool in case so for the
tool in case we can just generalize the
algorithms that we have and and get
exactly the same without for km and
every graph and mountainous graph
instead of cutting a cycle you can
define what it means to be an
inconsistent cycle you go along the
constrained the cycle has to be violated
because the constant don't add up to be
0 and then and then you say it is an
inconsistent cycle and then you write an
LP ducati inconsistent cycle the same
analysis would work and then the
approximation would be independent of
how the unique games conjecture is
saying that the problem becomes harder
and harder when the alphabet size
becomes larger and larger but for for
this particular problem the
approximation ratio is independent of
how
and 4chan about unique games that I
haven't defined but Yui has defined this
psycho cutting algorithm doesn't work
because weather cycle can be satisfied
it's not only dependent on the cycle it
also depends on how you assign depending
on what value that you assigned to to
denote so and in those case we use the
low diameter graph decomposition in this
nice paper they actually guarantee a
stronger property not only that in each
cluster the graph distance is small in
the original graph they're actually
small in the cluster itself so in
particular in each cluster you can find
shortest path tree and then you can do
propagation rounding exactly as in Gupta
and how to solve the problem so if you
have a graph and then it has small
diameter and you can you can find a tree
and then you pick a node assign some
value to the node and then propagate to
to the remaining nodes using the tree
and if it is short then it works and we
give a worse approximation ratio in the
general case if they exist an assignment
i satisfy 1 minus epsilon fashion of
course bang we we find in assignments
that violate at most L times the square
root epsilon fraction of constraint and
founders genius graph we got square root
lucky epsilon so you can think of it s n
we find of some earlier STP algorithms
for example I think we match the result
of Luca for this STP approximation
algorithms for unique games and when the
genius is smaller it it is a little bit
better
okay so that is the first part of the
talk so now I want to motivate the
second part of the talk we suppose we
want to design an algorithms to disprove
the unique games conjecture we can
afford to delete 1% of the edges and and
do some craft decomposition we know that
unique games easy on expander graphs we
also know that unique games are easy if
each graph is of pamda diameter so
suppose we can delete 1% of the edges in
a graph and then in each remaining
component it is an expander or if it is
of low diameter then we are done so in
fact in some sense it is also exactly
what Aurora Barak and style does in
their sub exponential time algorithms
they do a graph decomposition procedure
and then after cutting 1% of edges each
component has feel smaller plastic
eigenvalues and then they use
cholestatic
of eigenspace elaboration to solve to
solve each cluster ok so now it seems a
graph decomposition is important to
soften unique games so we we're
interested in finding a good
decomposition so first of all it is not
true that if we are looking for the
property of conductance and diameter
that's the best we can do we cannot
delete 1% of the edges and make every
component of constant expansion the best
we can do is to make each component of
conductance one of us login similarly to
the low diameter graphic box the
composition we cannot make it constant
diameter we can only make it out of time
Interlaken for example the hypercube is
is is one such graph
so this lock and loss is too bad for the
unique games problem then our
approximation ratio would be depend on n
and and we cannot disprove the unique
games conjecture so the questions that
we would like to ask is is there we
relaxed property of local tetons hike on
Tetons and low diameter so that we can
actually prove a stronger decomposition
result without this lock and loss okay
so what we proposed is poverty would be
good enough
yeah but we cannot get either so the
property that we propose is to study
effective resistance so we think about
the graph as electrical network each
edge the edge weight instead of thinking
of it as the length it is the
conductance of an edge or you can think
of it as the resistance resistance is 1
over WG the effective resistance between
two nodes U and V is defined as the
potential difference between the two
node if we inject one unit of current to
you and extract one you need two current
away from V so there different ways to
understand it it is called effective
resistance because you think of the
whole graph as a big resistor you ask
the question if I inject one unit of
current in you and take one unit of
current away from B if I think of the
whole graph as a big resistor what is
the effective resistance so that is the
potential difference between the two
nodes so there is one intuition and
another way to think about it is it is
the minimum energy to send one unit of
flow from you to B where the energy is
defined as some of the resistance times
the flows square on that edge
okay so what do we know about effective
resistance so first of all we can see
that it is a relaxation of the two
properties if the distance between two
note is small if I give resistance
between them is also small it is very
easy we just send one unit of flow from
you to be using the shortest path it is
also known maybe it's not as easy to see
is if I have a constant expansion graph
then the effective resistance between
any pair of notice at most a constant so
the two properties you can think of
effective resistance as a relaxed
property of low diameter and graph
expansion okay intuitively it is not a
bad relaxation because usually when we
think about a graph having no effective
resistance between two points we think
of the graph as having many shot
disjoint path connecting the two points
that's why the effective resistance is
small that's how you can minimize the
energy by by sending the flow along
different routes to 2v okay maybe I give
some more motivations about effective
resistance before I state main result so
traditionally effective resistance is
related to parameters of random walks
and random spanning trees it is exactly
proportional to the heating time of two
note it is closely related to the cover
time if we do random walk and is we also
know effective resistance of energy is
exactly the probability of energy in a
random spanning tree and more recently
the effective resistance is useful in
surprising ways in different problems it
is useful in craft specifications in
computing maximum flow in finding thin
tree and also in Ghent in fast
generation of random spanning trees so
this last work is closely related to us
because they also want to decompose
DeGraff into pasta with
small effective resistance such that the
cover time is small and I think maybe it
is also a natural question in yourself
we want to do graph partitioning but we
use effective resistance as a distance
measure it also satisfied triangle
inequality and if you think about maybe
I do graph partitioning you know so so
network effective resistance is a good
measure if two people they have ten
common friends they are closer to two
people who have only one common friend
and instead of just using a shortest
path distance so what our main result is
about graph decomposition using
effective resistance for any weighted
graph and for any large enough constant
they exist a partition of the vertex set
such that the resistance diameter is
small meaning that if you look at each
cluster look at every two pawns the
effective resistance is at most Delta
Delta you think of it as a large
constant times and divided by the total
weight in the graph and the only few
edges between clusters number of edges
that we need to remove is is at most a
constant fashion of the total weight
maybe you think of Delta as 1,000 so we
just remove 10% of the edges induced
subgraph yeah it is a stronger
know some okay
some partition we don't really check
okay
what I'm confused about is if you
multiply all the weights by 2 Delta n
over W be like yeah it is not because if
you give me a graph where every Edge has
very small weights which means by we
high effective resistance high
resistance on such an edge then the
diameter pound we can hope would be
weaker so maybe let me give you a
concrete example say let's say we just
respect to unweighted P Bakula graph and
then some of the edge weight would be
exactly equal to 2 e number of edges in
the graph then we can decompose the
graph into components such that each
component is of resistance diameter
cousin over D and we only delete a
constant fashion of edges so I want to
say that this is actually the optimal
thing to do in terms of these electrical
properties because if you have a graph
with maximum degree T the effective
resistance is at least 4 mega 1 over T
because you just have a minute
and and you you need a lot of energy to
cross the cut and a constant expansion
expander what would keep would give you
we say centimeter 1 over D so although
we cannot be composed a graph into
constant expansion graph but we can
decompose into into components with the
same optimal electrical properties
it's the statement I am about to stop
soon so the main clinical without that
we prove to prove this decomposition is
the following statement we said that if
if you look at every cut suppose you're
given two notes U and V if you look at
every cut separating you and B if the
number of edges crossing the cut is at
least C times volume one-half plus
epsilon it has to be greater than
one-half a little bit then the effective
resistance is bounded by this maybe it
is a little difficult to pass this
equation but I think the main point to
notice is the expansion requirement is
much weaker for for large set for large
set the conductor's requirement is
sublinear usually when you talk about
the conductance you say is C times the
volume of s but we just say C times the
square root volume of s is enough to
guarantee you have a small effective
resistance so that is the main point and
then the proof not difficult both proofs
are not difficult the first proof is
little similar to to what you do in
Chika's in kotti you just look at the
potential factor and then you look at
other narrow set you said if you have
good expansion on each level sets then
the potential difference would be small
and then you use it to about the
potential difference between U and B and
then the square root would come out and
then the second without is just to keep
applying the first result keep cutting
the graph and because the conductance is
sublinear you would have a geometric
decreasing sequence and then you don't
have this lock and loss
let me just end with two open questions
I think there there are few interesting
questions that you can ask about this
decomposition but I just asked - one is
for fast algorithms people can you
compute this decomposition in near
linear time we can use laplacian server
to compute a cut and the total running
time is M times n but maybe you can do
it in the linear time and the other
question is for approximation people
there are some natural problems
non-trivial problems that we know how to
solve it more effectively if we
guarantee that the graph has found the
effective resistance diameter so ideally
that would be unique games maybe
propagation rounding would work better
in such graphs and then and then that
would be good but if it doesn't work out
that way are there are some other
problems that you would work ok so I
will stop here
[Applause]
yes maybe more like their IP was pretty
good expander at some level not maybe it
was a lot of factors a 3d cube is one it
can't be more than two
it is a relaxation of the two properties
but somehow it gives you more if the
diameter is large you you know that
there could be many paths between them
it's kind of an out of relaxation of the
after two properties more questions okay
otherwise enjoy your lunch break stay
safe
[Applause]